enfin la dénonciation par pierre mauroy
de l'intervention des forces de police
contre les locaux de radio quinquin à
auby près de douai je vous le disais en
effet hier soir le gouvernement a choisi
l'épreuve de force contre les radios
libres
c'est hier soir que la police a décidé
d'intervenir contre cette radio pirate
qui bravent le monopole d'état depuis le
début du mois d'avril au cours de
l'opération la police a procédé à
plusieurs vérifications d'identité sur
les 45 personnes interpellées dix
militants cgt seront présentés ce soir
au parquet pour avoir violemment résisté
aux forces de l'ordre dans la nuit
d'hier
selon les enquêteurs des photos prouvent
que ces personnes lançaient des
projectiles sur les policiers qui ont
riposté avec des grenades lacrymogènes
selon la cgt le matériel radio de nancy
coeur d'acier a pu être déménagé avant
l'arrivée des forces de l'ordre ce qui
n'est pas le cas à paris pour radio
paris 80 investi hier ainsi que radio
quinquin près de douai qui émettait
depuis sept mois